let's go back to the phones a lot of
people holding 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 why
don't we go to the 3 1 3 area code
that's looking good to me caller from
three one three go ahead hi David how
are you doing today good how are you
who's this good my name is Anne from
Detroit and alright so Ian let's take
just two a quick pause we're not on
speakerphone are we because we're having
some horrible time hearing you
oh you're not on fun anymore okay not
anymore okay good speak up as much as
you can all right yeah no it's about the
rushed investigation I just want to ask
you isn't it basically a little
irrelevant to talk about another country
interfering in our election not just
considering the fact that we have
multiple times of tried and succeeded in
attempting to interfere in other
people's elections the only reason the
works set right now I believe is because
they succeed it am I wrong
so you're saying they did succeed it
sounds like well I mean they prefer
Trump over Hillary I'm sure and so you
so you're saying so I'm just trying to
understand the foundation of your
question is that Russia did succeed in
influencing our election that does is
that what you're saying no no I'm just
saying given that I was always under
that something that at the highest
levels of government it was always
assumed that all countries are trying to
interfere in all all other countries
elections they are us is always trying
to meddle in Russia Iran is Moldova
trying to influence Argentinian
elections oh I mean I'm sure maybe it's
not as important they know quite as many
resources towards as they would towards
China for example all right but I'm sure
they do because it's the Russian has a
sense interest in one candidate the CIA
isn't gonna sit back and just feel like
okay whatever happens I know they're
gonna try it will push the other side
try to make that guy one and said right
so that's true I just I just figured
look that is why we have
counter-intelligence department in our
intelligence agents so is that let me
see if I can understand even if I can
understand the question you're saying is
there not some hypocrisy
that we interfere in other countries
elections and now we're mad Russia
interfered in ours is that the question
well no I'm just saying it's irrelevant
that they interfered in our election
because it's not like we didn't expect
it was a complete surprise this is why
we have counterintelligence to defend
against intelligence operations against
the United States well it's for it's
like so I'm just trying to understand so
is your argument that Russia's
interference in our election even if
successful is irrelevant because it was
predictable
well because it's intelligence
intelligence community's job to predict
this thing this is what they're paid for
that's why they get billions and
billions of dollars this is brand-new we
have embassies and like a lot of funds
out the world who act and write there's
a sort of spies for the United States
against that country
yeah but Ian if I may what's the
argument like so it sounds like you're
saying because we have an apparatus
meant to predict these things the fact
that it happened is irrelevant Richard
Clarke provided a memo before 9/11 to
condi rice and George W Bush saying bin
Laden poised to strike the US and then
9/11 happened was 9/11 irrelevant
because we have an apparatus meant to
predict attacks against the US I just I
want to understand your argument well
the thing is it's not what the
intelligence community didn't know about
9/11 there's a lot of the committee
points affect the knew that was going to
happen actually in some ways I wanted it
to happen
okay so I mean that so you're now
bordering into into conspiracies that
the US intelligence community wanted
9/11 to happen which is not very far
from Bush did it but you're so you're
getting a little dangerously close to
some pretty wacky stuff but what is
what's your argument
I don't know if he's gone or if he's
just not talking anymore because he's
still online oh I'm sorry oh it's just
all right man that that's good I think
we've got enough out of I don't know
that there is an argument there